and now you've got something uh to
remember it forever
yes i have a tattoo you have a tattoo
yes i do yeah yeah i know well it's i
feel silly now because she i'm really
proud of you
thank you where did you get it yeah oh
but it's a celebrity tattoo oh dakota
johnson did it oh did she name it yeah
where is it that's little
i know it's okay this room is one it's
really small it's just initials of my my
most loved people oh that's adorable
have you got any ingram no i thought
when i'm about like 85 just go
completely tackle yeah because then you
won't get bored of it yes because you'll
be dead
wow and there are places that you don't
do them on your ribs if you're a
first-timer
going for a tattoo do not go for your
wrist bad idea the easiest place to do
it
for some people oh okay for some my hips
were the easiest do you know the best
tattoo i ever saw i saw a guy working
out in a gym with his shirt off like big
guy muscly shirt off two diamonte
earrings and like frosted tips hair he'd
done it all to look amazing and he was
working out and across his shoulder
blades it said only god can judge me and
i thought incorrect i can you're [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you